you know how that I actually love our  local sharing sharing affection fixin  love love and mercy mercy what's wrong  movie why don't you always have to find  something wrong with everything even  taymiyah said that some people are like  flies they always assume the worst and  land on bad places they never assume the  good in people and generally with  everything we should be amongst those  who when we hear about somebody or  whatever it may be to always assume the  best even if it's negative to say you  know what let's see something good  rather than bad right sister daily Salam  from me and hi - me response Allah grant  you Jenna  [Laughter]